[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plus tard
chez moi tu peux pas mais berger jeu
mais même une nuitée enfin fait un truc
je peux pas en ce moment parce que j'ai
vachement mes parents ils sont là il
perd souvent un peu en plus ma mère est
enceinte
félicitations donc je peux pas du tout
vraiment sinon qu'est ce qui t'arrive
mari mais non mais non plus le cac est
chez moi et du coup pas elle je suis
perdu je sais pas quoi faire tant mais
vient à la maison tu peux pas rester
comme ça m'arrive à temps mais jamais de
la vie je te laisserais comme ça
t'inquiète pas tu viens la maison tu
restes autant de temps que tu veux tu
prends tous tes vêtements des mises est
tout ce que tu as envie de prendre qui
était comme chez toi tu restes autant
que tu veux
il n'y a aucun souci c'est toujours les
mêmes qui ne prend pas perso c'est pas
perso non c'est cool on pourra se
rapprocher et tout parle un petit peu de
trucs ouais c'est pas vrai elle t'a fait
tout ça sans des gîtes à filmer comme
d'hab ah ouais vois-tu monfroy la
sextape sur le mail on croirait pas
qu'elle est si folle
ah ouais vraiment coquine un bon ok je
te remercie je t'embrasse c'est la très
vite au sacré patoche ok pour cyril
holtz marrer c'est un truc de ouf
pressé d'y être précédé de trois bisous
mon pote la soirée chronique on va se
marrer mon pote s'arrêter non on passe
une soirée de dingue avec tous les ans
et que c'est un truc de fou
selon sandrine et d'un invité à taper le
nom mais parce que peut-être ses parts
comme l'invitation et par mais peut-être
pas de mec toi sexy dance heure à dix
mètres points comme tout le monde à mon
mail je sais pas du tout ce que c'est je
pense à elle seule - francois guillot
well françois ouais ça lui fait ouais
il fallait même passionné
[Musique]